hello and welcome to gamespot of Thrones
you are watching just a small segment of
a much larger program where we discuss
in depth Game of Thrones season 6
episode 1 the red woman if you'd like to
see the full episode be sure to head to
youtube.com slash gamespot beware of
spoilers episode one of season six left
me feeling strangely optimistic for the
outcome of some of the characters in in
Westeros especially alien Alex answer
some nice allegiances were made people
got out of some tricky situations Kate
are we right to put our trust in george
RR martin that these characters are
gonna you know live happy long lives i
would love to say yes Lucy but every
time something good has happened even
when it's something bad happening to a
bad character it always gets flips you
know like Joffrey dies and you're like
yes finally button all the good people
get blamed they get put in prison they
have to escape it all sounds horrible
again it turns sour in your mouth and
I've actually been analyzing how george
RR martin writes these seasons with
obviously the writers of the next few
seasons because those books don't exist
yet come on search at the start of each
season right everything always seems
quite peachy so in season 4 you've got
overran swooning around being like I'm
great I'm going to revenge everybody and
then he dies you've got dinero's getting
some dragons and then the dragons you
know go through their awkward teenage
years and that's what happening right
now you've got robbed winning the war
and then you know the red wedding so
every time a season starts it goes hey
maybe he'll turn out okay and they never
do so bear that in mind so in this
episode we've got Sansa and Theon being
friends finally retention Brienne
turning up and saving them just to the
last minute that was good that wouldn't
normally happen normally they die and
that would be the end of them and you've
got divorce going maybe we can be saved
by the world links you've got area being
maybe being trained to be a badass in
Braavos where no one's trying to
kill her yet but no they're all gonna
die or the very least something awful
will happen to them what I find quite
interesting is that weirdly I see a lot
of parallels between george RR martin
and ramsey ramsay has it's very it's a
very manipulative streak and sometimes
he can use it to sort of gain people's
affection so if you think about like
when he was talking to Theon he builds
him up because he needs him to do
something he builds him up and then
ultimately just says you know like at
the last minute pulls the rug out from
under his feet is like but remember who
you are I feel like George does that a
lot with some of the story likes he'll
he makes you think that you're safe and
you're fine and then he just sort of
completely kills all the characters you
love or just has a little mini mne
genocide a wedding or yeah you know it's
it's very manipulative but I can't deny
that I absolutely love it so speaking of
Ramsey actually this is another theory
that I have at the end of every single
season it tends to end well for at least
one person so season one you've got
Joffrey who's just killed Ned to prove
his power and kind of you know torture
Sansa you've got De Niro since season
one as well who gets some dragons
dragons are good season two you've got
robbed who's starting to win this war
season three you've got Stannis who
starts to sacrifice children that's not
good i'll step but what turns out is
that every time the thing that they've
done to make that season end well for
them turns out to be their downfall so
Joffrey killing Ned you know that starts
a war that's bad De Niro sketched
dragons they turn out to be kind of
difficult who would know and so at this
end of season five I had a look it's
ramsey in the sand snakes who are doing
the best hmm like all they're doing is
going around killing people but that
makes them powerful but that could come
back to bite them in the ass and at the
end of season five we have Loras being
not very secretive about his sexuality
and being like what everybody knows and
we think that that might actually become
one of the pot lines in this season so
so what you're saying is george RR
martin is a sadist and we're masochistic
for enjoying every thrones we're reek
worry kids we used to be Theon we used
to be in a position of power not anymore
we can be Theon again he chops off a bit
metaphorically oh goodness Oh take your
poor face